sie ließen
hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner tochter
heute gibt's was typisch
vorweihnachtliches oder weihnachtliches
ich werde heute nämlich gebrannter
mandeln machen und das weg geht wirklich
ganz einfach und wenn ihr das essen
selbst macht werdet ihr auch schnell
merken dass die jets gemachten
gebrannten mandeln noch viel besser
schmecken als auf dem weihnachtsmarkt
und ich zeige ich es einfach mal die
ganz wenigen zutaten und zwar habe ich
hier 200 gramm mandeln 100 milliliter
wasser 100 milliliter zucker ich nehme
doch einen teelöffel sind und eine prise
salz als vorbereitung habe ich hier ein
backblech genommen und bereits mit
meinem back trance vol 1 gesprüht das
brauchen wir gleich und ansonsten
brauchen wir nur eine pfanne und im koch
werkzeug in backöfen oder kochlöffel und
ich habe jetzt hier etwas weniger zucker
in vielen rezepten ist es so dass man
200 gramm mandeln und 200 gramm zucker
nimmt aber das ist mir dann meistens
viel zu süß und ihr werdet auch sehen
dass so die gebrannten mandeln auch
schon süß genug schmecken und einfach
gut schmecken
ich werde es heute gebrannten mandeln
auf dem herd machen in der pfanne
man kann sie aber auch in der mikrowelle
machen aber wir haben keine mikrowelle
zu hause deswegen zeige ich euch auf der
pfanne oder in der pfanne und ihr kennt
ja mein herr tesch etwas laut da fängt
sie da gleich an zu summen
aber da werden wir auch unsere lösung
akzeptieren
jetzt gebe ich hier das wasser rein und
den zucker
ich gebe da immer noch gerne viel salz
mehr dazu weil ich immer findet den
zuckerhaltigen sachen auch eine prise
salz dazu gehört und auch umgekehrt weil
dann einfach die süße viel besser aus
jetzt noch ihren teelöffel zimt und es
werde so lange verrührt bis es auf kocht
und bei diesem rezept haben wirklich
nichts schief gehen oftmals ist es bei
rezept nämlich nur so dass man zucker
karamellisieren lässt und dann die
mandeln mit einkommen und danach alles
problem dass der zucker viel zu schnell
verbrennt und so könnte dem einfach
entgegen kommen und sagen wir kochen ecm
an den sirup und hier kocht er auch
schon jetzt kommen direkt die mandel mit
dazu eine frühe ich hier einfach so
lange bis der wasserdampf komplett
verdunstet ist wie zieht man hier schon
dass der sirup etwas dicker wird
als ich hier am löffel und jetzt müssen
wir einfach warten bis das hier ob
komplett weg ist und das ist auch der
punkt was viele oft falsch machen und
zwar muss jetzt die das wasser verdunste
zeilen und dann wird der zucker erstmal
wieder trocken liegt aber um die mandeln
herum wie viel dampf und dann wird der
zucker noch karamellisiert und das ist
es wo wir dann ganz arg aufpassen müssen
also das sieht man jetzt hier gleich
auch ganz genau
jetzt kommt auch langsam das schöne
weihnachtliche luft und zimt und mandeln
und gleich riechen wir dann auch das
karamell gleich ins parlament jetzt
verschwindet hier die flüssigkeit
und dann werden auch gleich wieder
zuckerkristalle sehen und dann
karamellisieren
und man sieht jetzt auch ganz deutlich
dass da genug zucker mit dabei ist weil
einfach jede mandeln komplett mit zucker
bedeckt ist und die süße recht wirklich
komplett aus und jetzt riecht auch schon
sehr lecker und massiert so langsam
kommen die zuckerkristalle wieder das
wird jetzt trocken eben hat es einen
schönen glanz jetzt wird es wieder matt
und dann wird wieder glänzt sich und
dann ist es auch wichtig sei jetzt
trocken
und jetzt muss der zucker
karamellisieren und das richtet hier
daheim in einer küche sowie auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt und übrigens haben wir
auch weil es hier weihnachtsmarkt also
im november/dezember fängt es ja an und
wir werden hier bei uns in waghäusel
auch einen weihnachtsmarkt machen und da
haben wir dann auch in den stand das
heißt das sage ich euch noch mal
bescheid aber da dürfte auch gern
vorbeikommen um uns bis zum kunden jetzt
einfach nicht mehr so kräftig rühren
sondern warten bis es eben
karamellisiert da reicht auch wenn ihr
langsam wird es davon nicht verbrennen
sonst wird's bitter aber wir haben es
gleich geschafft und dann dürft ihr den
moment nicht verpassen
kommt man hier runter und jetzt haben
wir wieder schöne glänzende gebrannter
mandeln die riechen richtig weihnachten
und jetzt nehme ich sie auch schnell
herunter damit mir die das karamell hier
nicht verbrennt und gibst du hier auf
meinem vorbereitetes bhak bhas einfach
mal drauf geben
und jetzt verteidigt es hier mit dem
löffel damit sie jetzt nicht zu einem
brocken zusammenkleben
wir wollen ja einzelnem anderen
jetzt nehme ich mir einfach zwei gabeln
und wird jetzt die mandeln voneinander
trennen
dass ich zwei bisschen mühselig aber ich
finde wenn man einzelne man hat einfach
schön
das ganze hat jetzt in etwa so zehn
minuten gedauert bis hierher und das ist
wirklich was was sehr schnell geht und
man kann es gut vorbereiten man kann
schön verschenken wenn man es gepackt
man kann es machen wir mal abends auf
der couch sitzen einfach lust auf süßes
hat
nach etwa drei vier minuten sind die
mandeln so sehr abgekühlt dass ich sehr
anpassen kann und mich nicht mehr
verbrenne und dann nehme ich einfach die
hände und kann sie ein bisschen
auseinander brechen geht etwas schneller
als mit der gabel
aber dann ist er wirklich warten dass
ihr euch einfach nicht die finger
verbrennt ich werde jetzt die
rechtlichen mandeln auseinanderbrechen
plätze komplett ausbilden lassen und
dann machen wir noch die geschmacksprobe
und jetzt sind die mandeln abgekühlt und
wir haben hier heute eine super hübsche
tüte gebastelt mit der karima wie steht
heute wieder hinter der kamera und
visite gebastelt wurde zeige ich euch am
ende des videos
ihr könnt aber auch wenn er seine tüte
nicht haben oder kein händchen dafür
habt dann könnt ihr zum beispiel auch
einen spritzbeutel nehmen und den
einfach etwas kürzer schneiden oder es
gibt ja auch so kleine tüten die eben
extra für süßigkeiten gedacht sind und
dann kann man die mandeln eben schön
verschenken in dem was er oben noch zu
bewerten die fülle ich jetzt da einfach
noch ein
sprich und
lecker also für mich könnte man sogar
ein bisschen mit senf dazugeben ich wer
sonst
und das rezept gibt natürlich zum
nachlesen auf sell off - blog.de und ihr
könnt mir mal schreiben was für euch so
eine typische weihnachtssüßigkeiten ist
auf dem weihnachtsmarkt zum beispiel ich
bin so der typ ich gehe zum
weihnachtsmarkt trinkt erstmal kinder
kunst und dann hole ich mir eine tüte
gebrannte mandeln obwohl selber auf ganz
gut gehen man kann es ja daheim machen
aber auch im weihnachtsmarkt schmeckt
einfach anders streuber da in der
atmosphäre dabei ist und ich freue mich
schon richtig auf die zeit und freue
mich zu hören oder zu lesen was eben für
euch so die typische spezialität ist und
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
und im anschluss verlinke ich euch noch
im video was ihr euch gerne anschauen
könnt bis bald
übrigens wird dieses wochenende richtig
ereignisreich denn der bülent ceylan
kommt zu uns nach waghäusel in den
globus und zwar am samstag 13 dezember
zwischen 13 und 14 uhr gibt er
autogramme
da werde ich natürlich auch mit dabei
sein das kann ich ja nicht verpassen ich
nehme natürlich auch meine kamera mit
und der bühne geht dann anschließend
auch sein event nach karlsruhe
da hat er samstag und sonntag seinen
auftritt und ich geh nach kanada kids
wissen weihnachtsmarkt und da habe ich
meinen eigenen stand da gibt's dann auch
zu essen und zu trinken und kinderwunsch
und alles mögliche und ich würde mich
freuen wenn ihr vorbeikommt ich führe
euch gleich noch ein foto an und da
stehen dann noch mal die genauen daten
und ich freue mich schon richtig auf
euch und hoffe dass zahlreiche oder dass
zahlreiche zuschauer bei kommen damit
ich euch auch mal kennenlernen kann
bis samstag oder sonntag
also logisch preise mussten
ja
und wenn es einfach ein bisschen kleiner
aktion massiv kleiner
platz für immer dreieck ist die
grundschullehrerin kriegt es nicht in
eine tüte zu basteln
das sagen haben
zipfel und den ich könnte jetzt
umknicken oder den knicks und das gehört
auch so bist schön eigentlich müsst ihr
das so gut wie nichts halt so kleine und
das klebeband fixiert zu
vielleicht sollten wir einen bastel
kanal eröffnet ich wollte sagen soll die
tüte davor geschützt dass sie nicht
wieder aufgeht liebe zuschauer die tüte
gibt
wir starten heute